[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
parlement hebdo l'émission qui revient
sur les temps forts de l'actualité à
l'assemblée nationale et au sénat avec
tam tran huy nous sommes très heureuses
de recevoir cette semaine sophie primas
bonjour et bienvenue et cette âme qui
dresse votre portrait bonjour sophie
primas vous êtes sénatrice l ère des
yvelines depuis 2011
ingénieur agronome de formation vous
présidez la commission des affaires
économiques depuis trois ans où vous
avez eu notamment à gérer la détresse
des agriculteurs
vous êtes devenu député pour la première
fois en 2010 à la suite du décès d'henri
cuq cet ex ministre de jacques chirac
dont vous étiez la suppléante
pour la petite histoire sa permanence
parlementaire se trouvait à deux maisons
de celle de vos parents que votre
engagement à droite c'est une histoire
de famille finalement oui c'est une
histoire d'amitié de conviction bien sûr
et de famille ce que vous ne savez pas
c'est qu'entre la permanence et la
maison de mes parents
il y avait la maison de la d2 la
sénatrice maire nelly rodi qui a siégé
ici pendant neuf ans voilà la droite
pour laquelle vous vous êtes engagé à la
changer aujourd'hui la droite pour
laquelle je me suis engagé à ce qu elle
a changé je pense qu'en fait c'est les
repères qui ont changé la société à
changer vite je trouve que la droite
pour laquelle je me suis engagé était
très proche de la population qui est la
constitution de mon bassin de vie elle
est plus populaire elle était clair moi
j'aimais j'aimais le rpr bien sûr ce que
j'étais issu de cette famille là mais
j'aimais aussi l'ump parce que dans
notre sigle il y avait populaire et je
trouve qu'aujourd'hui un match aller
reste baker ouais ça on ne s'adresse
plus assez en tout cas cet électorat-là
qui en a bien besoin et qu'on laisse un
peu à l'abandon d'autres partis
politiques - république qu'est ce qu'il
ya comme une personnalité à droite dans
lequel vous retrouvez bien ce caractère
populaire que vous recherchez
aujourd'hui
oui il ya plusieurs personnalités qui
aujourd'hui tentent d'entrer sur ce sur
ce domaine politique là je dirais qu'il
ya plusieurs personnalités plusieurs
compétences voilà on va voir si le
puzzle fait qu'elle annuel
il a l'image au bout non mais je me
retrouve ce qui s'est dit et bertrand
moreau dans les champs je me retrouve
dans des champs différents sur des
personnalités je me retrouve proche de
valérie pécresse forcément on fait de là
on fait de la politique ensemble
territorialement mais je trouve que la
proche de xavier bertrand est
intéressante je trouve que la compétence
de françois baroin est irremplaçable je
trouve là donc je trouve qu'il ya un
puzzle de compétences il va falloir
aller chercher toutes ses compétences et
les mettre dans un seul homme ou d'une
seule femme voilà voici à présent les
titres de cette émission l'allègement du
confinement
comment ce week-end les commerces
rouvrent mais pas les restaurants jean
castex l'a confirmé jeudi lors d'une
conférence de presse les sénateurs
poursuivent l'examen du budget 2010 21
les discussions autour du plan de
relance ont été houleuses jeudi
l'absence de bruno le maire dans
l'hémicycle a fortement énervé les
parlementaires la proposition de loi sur
la sécurité globale voté en première
lecture à l'assemblée nationale elle a
été largement contestées dans
l'hémicycle comme en dehors
l'article 24 va être réécrit et on
commence avec l'allègement du
confinement qui commence ce week-end
[Musique]
jeudi le premier ministre jean castex a
assuré le service après vente est
confirmée le déconfinement en trois
étapes
les commerçants sont autorisés à rouvrir
dès ce week-end mais pas les restaurants
qui devront attendre au moins jusqu'au
20 janvier
la première phase qui s'ouvrira donc
samedi samedi 28 novembre au matin sera
une phase d'allègement du confinement
avec la reprise d'un certain nombre
d'activités les déplacements resteront
contre et l'attestation obligatoire pour
toutes les sorties du domicile le 15
décembre s'ouvrir à une deuxième phase
avec un système de couvre-feu à 21h sur
l'ensemble du territoire qui remplacera
le confinement l'attestation sera
supprimée en journée mais restera
obligatoire
en soirée le 20 janvier si la période
des fêtes de fin d'année ne s'est pas
traduite par un rebond de l'épidémie
alors nous pourrons envisager de lever
le couvre-feu et d'autoriser la reprise
d'activité pour les restaurants les
enseignements en présentiel dans
l'enseignement supérieur et le retour à
un fonctionnement normal dans tous les
lycées
sophie primas alors jean castex a donné
de très nombreux détails je dis bon la
première mesure c'est tout de même la
réouverture des commerces dès ce week
end l'un des premiers sujets de
préoccupation pour vous vous le saluer
vous êtes satisfaite
oui je suis satisfaite vous savez ça
paraît comme une bonne nouvelle
la vraie bonne question c'est pourquoi
on a fermé en réalité et qu'est ce qui a
amené c'est la décision de fermer bennoo
on n'aurait pas dû faire pour classer
les néo la semaine population s'était
pas une raison suffisante n'ont en fait
rien ne prouve que la contamination se
faisait évidemment dans l'est dans les
petits commerces on a eu une série de
décisions qui ont été faites sans aucune
allégation sanitaire derrière totalement
incompréhensible et qui participe à la
confusion en fait pour les français et
trouve les choses complètement injuste
pas très logique en réalité et même
dans les décisions qui ont été prises là
je salue la réouverture le desserrement
un petit peu de l'économie mais ils
attendent jusqu'à 21h les ouvertures lui
- morizet je le demande ça va permettre
de rattraper comme ici sur votre plateau
je demandais à la fois qu'on les ouvre
rapidement les commerces pour éviter que
tout le monde se retrouve dans les mêmes
horaires dans les mêmes journées sur
quatre semaines au lieu de 8 dans les
magasins pour faire les courses de noël
donc oui je salue ça mais je je je dis
quand même que le manque de logique
entre les secteurs d'activité voilà nuit
a nui à l'acceptabilité de ces
contraintes par les français nous parler
de logique vous parler d' incohérences
là il a été assouplie la la jauge pour
les personnes qui veulent aller dans les
lieux de culte donc ses trente personnes
c'est ce qu'a décidé le président de la
république ça vous paraît logique
cohérent mais voilà c'est typiquement
dans les lieux de culte 30 personnes
donc entre la collégiale de
mantes-la-jolie et la chapelle de cours
gens que tout petit où on peut pas faire
de distanciation je pense qu'il ya un
peu de logique et un peu de confiance
sera peut-être un assouplissement à
partir du 15 décembre ça se fait en
trois étapes
celle ci n'a t-il vous voyez c'est
inutile parce que ça vient ébranler en
fait la confiance qu'on a dans
l'ensemble du groupe
voilà sept cet illogisme en tout cas
voilà vient ébranler l'ensemble du plan
je trouve les stations de ski aussi sont
vent debout
on va pouvoir respirer le bon air de la
montagne a déclaré jean castex mais pas
prendre les remontées mécaniques votre
réaction à à se proposer ça pose des
problèmes économiques
énorme aux stations aux collectivités
territoriales qui ont des stations de
sports d'hiver de fréquentation des
hôtels a vraiment la montagne va être
dans une période extrêmement difficile
peut-être qu'en anticipant un petit peu
les choses à partir de septembre à
partir de l'été on aurait pu mettre des
protocoles pour que les remontées
mécaniques fonctionnent un peu au
ralenti mais fonctionne quand même vous
réclamez cette réouverture ou pas dès
noël ce n'est pas possible aujourd'hui
mais je pense que si on travaille avec
les professionnels de la montagne nous
doit prouver de trouver des protocoles
pour ouvrir les stations là où il ya de
la neige naturellement bon alors bien
sûr la montagne c'est pas que le ski au
players plein de choses et on comprend
ainsi que des hôpitaux puissent vouloir
avoir des personnes voilà avoir des
accidents de ski donc voilà ça c'est
normal de savoie notamment où il ya des
beaucoup de cas de corne à la russe les
sols explique yves darry savait pas
aboyer ça il faut l'expliquer aux
français c'est parce qu'on a expliqué
aux français on leur a dit vous allez
vous bousculer sur leur montant tu sais
pas ça en fait en réalité le vrai sujet
qui est derrière s'est effectivement
sujet hospitalier l'engorgement des
sites des gens des résurgences en cas de
trauma voilà qui arrive au ski
malheureusement et par rapport aux kovy
donc ça c'est un vrai sujet là aussi on
peut peut-être imaginer des solutions
pour alléger les hôpitaux de la partie
qu'ovide enfin voila je pense que là
aussi ça manque d'anticipation c'est à
se casser une jambe ou les polos ce
qu'ils ont fait est que ça arrive
voilà donc on sait qui est des accidents
connaît le taux d'accidentologie enfin
voilà tout ça ça s'anticipe et je pense
qu'il ya une autre question qui se pose
maintenant c'est sur l'isolément des
malades y aura un projet de loi dit jean
castex est ce que demandait d'ailleurs
gérard larcher est-ce qu'il faut rendre
obligatoire cet isolement et ce qu'il
faut mettre une amende en cas de non
respect de cet isolement
moi je suis frappé
depuis quelques semaines et quelques
mois par toutes ces lois qui ne pensent
qu'à mettre des amendes
j'en appelle à la responsabilité des uns
et de chacun d'entre nous et cette
responsabilité elle va de pair avec la
liberté individuelle vous voyez que si
vous êtes une mère de famille que vous
êtes kobe de plus que vous pouvez pas
faire garder vos enfants
peut-être que l' isolement prend une
forme différente on devrait parler des
formes d'isolement parler des solutions
pour les français les systématiquement
interdire mettre des amendes et on
al'impression enfin d'un système
extrêmement de ran et l'accompagnement
canada manque une contrainte bien sûr il
faut et a peut être insérée dans un
projet de loi pour vous ça peut être un
texte de changer de loi je pense pas que
ça nécessite d'un projet de loi enfin je
pense que tout un chacun est responsable
voilà moi j'en apprends que j'ai un
cousin keko vide plus depuis hier on bat
il est chez lui les en sachant qu'il
bouge pas on va aller lui mettre une
amende dans sa chambre si quelqu'un
vient lui donner un plateau enfin voyez
je trouve qu'on en vient à une
infantilisation de la société qui me
paraît être préjudiciable pour le bien
commun
en réalité une dernière question sur la
stratégie de vaccination
là encore le gouvernement veut saisir le
parlement
on apprend on sait déjà qu'il n'y aura
pas de vaccins obligatoires c'est une
bonne chose pour vous là je suis plus
nuancée parce que on est dans une
responsabilité collective sanitaires moi
je ne suis pas médecin donc je ne sais
pas mesurer si 60 ou 50 ou 60% de la
population se vaccine est-ce que c'est
suffisant pour avoir une limite et
générale je pense qu'on a une
responsabilité de solidarité
intergénérationnelle
global on se vaccine tous pour la polio
fin c'est comme ça qu'on a éradiqué un
certain nombre d'heures qu'il faudrait
peut-être voilà ma réponse est un peu un
peu sénatoriales peut-être mais j'ai
besoin d' expertise médicale pour vous
répondre davantage mais il me semble que
là il ya une responsabilité collective
très impressionnante on pourrait
l'imposer pour voyager ce qui
permettrait de ne pas le rendre
forcément obligatoire mais de le rendre
obligatoire pour certains trajets pour
éviter qu'il y ait des brassages de
population
peut-être transmettre ce qu'il faut
protéger aussi certaines populations il
faut qu'elle avait qu'elles soient
vigilantes du conte fragiles les plus
fragiles voilà je pense parce que là on
pourrait peut-être effectivement avoir
certains types de populations sur
lesquelles il faudra être très vigilant
allez on poursuit avec l'examen du
budget 2011 21 au sénat
[Musique]
au programme jeudi plan de relance et
plan d'urgence dans une ambiance
houleuse les sénateurs étaient furieux
car la ministre de l'économie bruno le
maire était absent de l'hémicycle cécile
6o on aborde la loi de finances on n'a
pas le ministre de l'économie des
finances et du plan de relance il
absence de bruno le maire du banc des
ministres pour débuter l'examen du plan
de relance n'est pas du tout passé
inaperçu tous les groupes politiques
irrité par cette désertion au pousser un
coup de gueule
nous ne sommes pas la voiture balai du
parlement français cette absence non
seulement répéter mais systématique
n'est pas respectueuse de l'équilibré
que représente le sénat dans le
parlement français cette absence c'est
un mépris aussi vis-à-vis de ceux et de
celles que nous représentons c'est à
dire les français avec humour hervé
marseille président du groupe centriste
a même proposé à olivier du soft seuls
ministres présents une petite promotion
on a beaucoup de sympathie pour vous
parce que justement c'est vous qui venez
nous voir
peut-être pourriez-vous devenir minutes
l'économie et des finances réponse gênée
du ministre du budget bruno le maire
avait un empêchement
il lui fera tout de même passer le
message je tiens à préciser que les
compétences dont je bénéficie ou que
j'exerce comme ministre délégué auprès
bono le maire me donne compétence sur
l'intégralité des actes budgétaires
au delà des reproches technique les
sénateurs ont critiqué lors de la
discussion générale le montant de 100
milliards d'euros communiquée par le
gouvernement un chiffre erroné selon eux
car ils le vont examiner que 36
milliards pour le budget 2021 100
milliards d'euros après analyse on
trouve de tout des mesures déjà engagées
en 2020 pour 15 milliards la baisse des
impôts de production pour 20 milliards
le financement de ségur de la santé les
sénateurs critique aussi un plan de
relance qui pour eux n'en ai pas
beaucoup de crédit sont des crédits de
mise à niveau des ministères le
rapporteur général l'a dit c'est plus un
plan de rattrapage au cours de l'examen
du texte les sénateurs qu'ont donc
réécrire ce plan de relance en mettant
l'accent sur la solidarité
il compte par exemple renforcer les
politiques de l'emploi des jeunes ou
encore faire évoluer le fonds de
solidarité
sophie primas d'abord un mot est bien
sûr l'absence de bruno le maire je dis
'comment est-ce que vous l'interprétez
est ce réellement un manque de respect
pour le parlement pour vous en réalité
ce qui s'est passé c'est que c'est
l'aboutissement d'un long procès ce
c'est à dire que l'absence de bruno le
maire dans la discussion générale du
budget fait suite à son absence quasi
permanente aux questions d'actualité
fait suite à l'absence totale d'olivier
ferrand sur sur le projet de loi de
finances de la sécurité sociale pendant
l'examen du texte et fait suite en fait
à une absence quasi permanente de tous
les ministres j'allais dire star de ce
bout là ce que ça veut dire monsieur
d'hermann à est rarement des femmes en
particulier oui ben je sais pas c'est ce
que c'est la question qui a été posée
pas par les différents présidents et
présidentes de groupe hier
voilà on voudrait parler au ministre
alors monsieur castex est là mais c'est
la moindre des choses était obligé mais
l'ensemble de ses ministres j'allais
dire vraiment fort condé
condé des compétences extrêmement
lourdes ne sont jamais là et monsieur
bruno le maire empêché enfin il était
quand même sur les plateaux de
télévision dans l'après midi
donc je trouve que on doit être devant
le parlement plutôt que devant les
plateaux de télévision d'ailleurs je te
ferai voilà je devrais y être mais vous
étiez dans l'émission j'étais dans
l'édition d'hier soir et j'ai été ce
matin et je serai demain mais mais voilà
je crois qu'on a besoin aussi d'être
respectés d'être entendu et je crois que
le grand malaise démocratique dans
lequel on se trouve aujourd'hui il vient
aussi de ça il vient du manque de
considération
de ce gouvernement pour le parlement
d'une façon générale et je parle pour le
sénat mais je parle aussi pour
l'assemblée nationale et on parlera
sûrement de la réécriture de l'article
24 et on va en parler mais là la force
là parlons de ce projet de loi de
finances il contient le plan de relance
100 milliards d'euros est ce qu'il peut
permettre de surmonter la crise selon
vous alors moi je voudrais dire d'abord
que il ya un chiffre choc et 100
milliards d'euros c'est un chiffre
évidemment extrêmement important c'est
un chiffre de communication c'est un
effort important de la nation pour la
relance mais c'est aussi un effort
important
j'allais dire dans le cas d'urgence
parce que comme l'a dit le président
reynal
tout à l'heure il ya de tout en fait
dans ces 100 milliards il ya un peu
d'urgence on met le chômage partiel
similaire de crédits budgétaires voit la
merde fiscal et ont met du pg on met de
la baisse de fiscalité on met des
crédits d'émission habituel écologie
politique de la ville on les remet dans
le plan de relance n'y a pas vraiment
100 milliards ce soit d'oka pas vraiment
100 milliards et c'est un petit peu un
jeu de bonne première sur deux ans et
ses cinq milliards sur deux ans c'est
ces 22 milliards en réalité qui sont
ouverts cette année en crédits de
paiement en 2020 alors je ne je ne peux
pas dire que c'est pas bien parce que
l'effort de l'aser ça suffise à être
conséquent mais on a un jeu en fait on
en sait plus rien c'est dire que le jeu
de bonneteau entre je prends des crédits
l'âge l'air mais là je prends dans le
plan d'investissements d'avenir je leur
mets là je prends un petit peu là je
leur mets là on a beaucoup de mal à voir
en réel et puis vous avez une dispersion
des crédits c'est à dire vous avez un
effort par exemple très bienvenu sur la
recherche sur l'hydrogène partants qui
me semble être là parfaitement dans le
plan de relance est parfaitement adéquat
et à côté de ça vous avez quelques
millions pour la numérisation des
ministères ou le développement des
jardins familiaux
enfin voyez on a une dispersion des
choses qu'ils portent à la confusion et
moi ce que j'aurais souhaité c'est que
ce plan de relance
ils soient orientés vers les
investissements des investissements
d'avenir pour la france et je trouve que
le discours aurait été plus facile à
porter plus facile à juger et plus
faciles à contrôler ensuite pas par par
la suite il ya une mesure importante
dans ce plan de relance et la baisse des
impôts de production
la droite est défavorable depuis
toujours ça vous le saluer ah oui je
salue les salue l'effort considérable
qui est fait puisque ces 10 milliards
vous savez que je regrette toujours
qu'on n'est pas favorisé cette mesure
par rapport à l'annulation de la taxe
d'habitation
ça me paraît être l'erreur du mandat en
termes de fiscalité mais je salue cette
baisse de fiscalité encore faut-il
savoir comment les collectivités
territoriales vont elles continuer à
être françois baroin à lui est vent
debout et dit que c'est là encore une
faute économique et politique pour lui
que cette baisse des impôts de
production qu'il met exactement sur le
même plan que l'erreur qui a été commise
pour lui sur la taxe d'habitation moi je
pense que ce que françois parent - veux
dire c'est que en réalité lui il est
garant des collectivités territoriales
et en particulier des des mairies de
l'autonomie fiscale finances cac les
financières donc c'est ça qui est en soi
cette baisse des armes et la baisse du
cours s'étaient demandés depuis toujours
le tout c'est comme en fait c'était un
peu l'idée de nicolas sarkozy quand il a
levé enlevait la taxe professionnelle
c'était très compliqué ça a été remplacé
par des taxes n'étaient pas parfaits
mais l'idée était là moi dans mon
territoire on a sauvé une usine
grâce à ça je pense que la baisse des
impôts de production les nécessaires
mais il faut la voir dans la grande
image de la fiscalité territoriale
parce qu'il ne faut pas enlever des
moyens aux collectivités territoriales
pour rendre attractif leur territoire
pour implanter des entreprises
on dépense de l'argent dans les
territoires la région les opci les
communes dépensent pour que leur leur
commune soit accessible à des
entreprises
allez on va terminer cette émission avec
l'adoption de la proposition de loi sur
la sécurité globale à l'assemblée
nationale
[Musique]
et cette proposition loi sur la sécurité
globale adoptée donc cette semaine en
première lecture à l'assemblée nationale
largement contestée par l'ensemble des
journalistes et des associations des
droits de l'homme et une partie de la
majorité elle devrait être réécrite
lors de son passage au sénat et via une
commission indépendante les précisions
dès l'amont un gamin pour 388 contre 104
la séance suspendue une proposition de
loi très largement adopté mais très
largement contesté également
c'est l'article 24 qui a concentré les
critiques
à l'origine il punissait d'un an
d'emprisonnement et de 45000 euros
d'amendé le fait de diffuser par
quelques moyen que ce soit et quel qu'en
soit le support
dans le but qu'il soit porté atteinte à
son intégrité physique ou psychique
l'image du visage ou tout autre élément
d'identification d'un agent de la police
nationale ou de la gendarmerie
nationales en opération de police devant
la contestation des journalistes et des
défenseurs des libertés publiques et la
pression d'une partie de la majorité le
gouvernement accepte finalement de
donner des gages
il ajoute sans préjudice du droit
d'informer et précise que le but de
porter atteinte à l'intégrité physique
ou psychique doit être manifeste de quoi
rassurer certains dans la majorité mais
pas tous
il me semble que cet article 24 bien
aujourd'hui uniquement faire de la
surenchère vient en plus rajouter à un
délit d'intention qui est toujours très
difficile à des caractères ise était
finalement 7 soit elle cette partie qui
les bavards et il est inutile au sein du
groupe la république en marche
220 pour 10 contre et 30 abstentions au
groupe modem 33 pour 5 contre et 18
abstentions
le texte devrait être examiné au sénat
au mois de janvier
la majorité de droite à d'ores et déjà
promis de réécrire intégralement ce
fameux article 24
sophie primas le premier ministre jean
castex a annoncé la création d'une
commission indépendante qui sera
présidée par jean marc burg bureau qui
est le président de la commission
nationale consultative des droits de
l'homme alors que justement le sénat
s'apprêtait
à réécrire cet article 24 du projet de
loi ce matin richard ferrandi sa vive
émotion quelle est votre réaction
je suis concernée je suis consterné
parce que pour fasse une commission
avant d'écrire un projet de loi d' avant
de faire un amendement ou avant de
déposer quelque chose sur le bureau du
conseil des ministres me semble être de
bon aloi toutes ces personnes que vous
avez cités sont de bons conseils
mais qu'on le fasse pendant la navette
parlementaire pour dire à l'assemblée
nationale vous avez mal légiférer vous
avez mal préparé les choses pour dire au
sénat ba écoute et vous verrez ce que
dit la commission mais c'est mal
connaître les instances de la république
le rôle de chacun le rôle du parlement
cdj ferrer c'est décrire la loi et on a
des gens extrêmement compétents santé
des saisies finalement de votre pouvoir
cette proposition dont je trouve ça
absolument scandaleux et encore une fois
c'est extra apporte de la confusion dans
l'esprit des français sur le rôle des
institutions et le rôle du parlement le
rôle du gouvernement
on doit on doit s'entourer de gens
compétents on doit consulter on doit
écouter ce qu'on vous dit où ton une
fois que le process législatif et est en
route
on doit respecter ce process ghislaine
ne souhaitait pas que cette commission
ait lieu mais il y aura plein d'audition
au sénat et c'est cet essai cette
commission en tout cas ces personnes
seront entendues par le sénat et elles
participeront à l'élaboration du texte
par le sénat
mais à chacun son rôle à chacun son rôle
dans un timing qui doit être respecté
sinon la confusion est totale
et franchement on n'a pas besoin de
confusion législatives dans ce moment de
confusion économique social sanitaire je
pense qu'il faut pas en rajouter
est ce que ça vaut même le coup de
garder cet article 24 quand on voit
combien il est aujourd'hui contesté cet
article dont l'ex président de la
commission des lois philippe bas a dit
qu'il avait été écrit avec les pieds je
ne suis pas assez compétente en matière
logistique pur pour avoir un avis si on
l'a écrit avec les mains avec les pieds
ou les oreilles ce que je sais c'est
qu'il ya un vrai sujet qui est un sujet
de protection de l'intégrité
des policiers et des personnes qui font
le maintien de l'ordre on a connu il ya
plein de façons de protéger les
policiers de volonté manifeste de nuire
c'est un article dans lequel je pense
qui fait défaut tout les étudier
celle-ci est peut-être un des éléments
mais mais pas du tout le seul et c'est
le plus maladroit qui puisse être et
qu'ils puissent avoir été introduit dans
cette loi je pense qu'il ya plein
d'autres méthodes
il faut être très vigilant aux libertés
individuelles à la liberté d'informer il
faut être aussi vigilant à la sécurité
de nos forces de l'ordre donc c'est cet
équilibre là on doit essayer de
retrouver un risque d' auto-censure des
journalistes avec ce texte on voit que
les forces de l'ordre risquent d'avant
on a vu très restrictive ça évidemment
on est évidemment l'éviter et puis comme
le disait la députée qui était interrogé
on ne peut pas légiférer sur un délit
d'intention face à n'existe pas on voit
que l'actualité rattrape finalement
cette proposition de loi il ya eu
l'évacuation musclée par les forces de
l'ordre d'un camp de migrants se déplace
de la république cette semaine et puis
un producteur qui a été tabassé
également cette semaine est traité de
sale est ce que finalement le
contexte politique n'a pas changé et
nécessite de aujourd'hui le retrait de
cet article 24
je pense qu'il faut soit le réécrire de
façon très claire en lien d'ailleurs
avec les journalistes avec un certain
nombre de partenaires soient
effectivement réécrire à côté une loi
pour protéger la police voilà de toute
intention manifeste de nuire
il ya un vrai sujet quand même vous
savez parce que quand on est en capacité
de remplacer la démocratie de remplacer
la justice par le tribunal populaire que
représente aujourd'hui les réseaux
sociaux je pense que là aussi on a un
risque
voyez on a un régional populaire ou
lanceurs d'alert aussi voilà c'est cette
c'est cet équilibre
la crainte cette ville de presse qu'il
faut trouver qui est très très compliqué
parce qu'on a besoin des lanceurs
d'alert aujourd'hui les lanceurs d
alerte
ça se transforme par la diffusion
massive de l'information rapide sans
beaucoup de réflexions en un tribunal
populaire et là c'est très dangereux
aussi pour les forces de l'ordre pour
tout le monde en réalité une toute
dernière question sur gérald darmanin
qu'ils aient aussi bien responsable de
tout ce climat si l'ap un petit peu joué
avec le feu avec ce texte pour vous un
petit peu je pense qu'il a eu des propos
avant la lecture du texte qui ont mis le
feu en réalité sur le droit de filmer
sur éventuellement une habilitation sur
le